[Musique]
la liste de rassemblement national est
peut-être la seule liste qui défend
clairement et qui a comme coeur de son
action politique la défense de l'intérêt
des français donc à dire vrai c'est vous
voulez vous considérer qu'un pays doit
avoir des frontières ont considéré que
les clandestins n'ont pas être
relocalisés dans vos villages que vous
considérez que 80% de la richesse ne
doit pas aller à 1% de la population et
que par exemple l'état peut aider des
entreprises privées à tenir le coup ou
alors l'état peut aider à rien de
réindustrialiser le pays
clairement il faut choisir leur semblant
nationale car c'est la seule liste qui
défend justement ce genre de le
localisme l'intérêt des français avant
toute chose nous prenons en europe des
coopérations
nous défendons l'alliance des nations
européennes une alliance donc qui a en
plus déjà eu des résultats
ariane arianespace par exemple est un
très bon exemple
la coopération est ce qui marche le
mieux entre des nations qui sont libres
souveraine dit de choisir ce qu'elles
veulent ou ne veulent pas pour leur
peuple
donc c'est l'or après nous défendons
c'est devenu une robe des libertés
chaque pays peut choisir de sa politique
nationale
on peut en effet choisir aussi avec qui
coopérer de manière privilégiée l'europe
est un espace culturel et politique
intéressant qui peut faire face en effet
au reste du monde donc il faut
travailler à cette coopération à cette
réponse face à la mondialisation mais en
même temps ça non plus ça n'occulte pas
le fait que ce qui prévaut toujours
c'est la liberté de chaque peuple
liberté de choisir si le telle ou telle
politique
[Musique]
l'urgence européenne est de rétablir
certaines frontières
la priorité est justement de rock trouve
se retrouver entre européens pour
pouvoir construire un avenir européen
en effet une immersion et des
conséquences économiques graves mais si
culturel et sécuritaire donc il est le
temps à mon avis pour apaiser l'ambiance
qu'il règne en europe de mettre des
frontières à cette europe
[Musique]